[Music]
one of the newest additions to the
skyline in hamburg germany is a concert
hall fit for a modern mozart
the elbphilharmonie is considered one of
the largest and most acoustically
advanced concert venues in the world
made up of three concert halls the elbow
fill harmony seats more than 2 800
visitors
the great concert hall the largest of
the three halls has ten thousand unique
acoustic panels that were designed using
computer algorithms to create the best
possible sound
each panel contains one million cells
that shape the sound by either absorbing
the waves or having them reverberate
through the space
the curved design of the cells can be
seen replicated throughout the entire
building
not to be outdone the glass exterior of
the elbow harmony built atop a former
warehouse is just as spectacular as the
interior
the structure rises above the elb river
and mirrors the water's wave and shine
to mark the opening night the exterior
featured a light show timed to the music
being played within the great hall
with multiple events almost every day
the elbphilharmony is a must-see for
music and math lovers alike
[Music]
you